so as I was just saying Dave James
thanks for sitting down with me but I've
been a fan girl this movie since South
by well you were there at the beginning
that's so cool you get to claim that yes
standing ovation what was it like for
you guys that was a huge night for us
for many reasons one of the sort of
business reasons was it had been made by
a new line and they were so great and so
supportive but they realized that maybe
the movie would fare better if it was
distributed by a 24 or a you know a
company like that we didn't have any 24
at the time and so they didn't have to
do it but they allowed us to take it out
and so that screening at South by was
the test like that had to go well a lot
was riding on it but in addition to that
Tommy Wiseau the real guy was there
seeing the movie for the first time and
he had always said that the book the
disaster I just heard my greg's is Tarun
Tom Bissell was only 40% true and so we
based our entire moon off of the book
yeah yeah we actually had no idea if you
would like it or hit it and then and
then afterwards I was like Tommy what
you think he's like well I proved 99.9%
and and you had to get him up on stage I
remember that y'all had to like there's
a lot of discussion beforehand whether
or not we'd bring him on stage and if we
were still worried that he you know
didn't like it and it you know we'd get
like that amazing reaction then he'd
come up on stage and be like they are
not true you know what I mean like what
a bummer but then the real Chris Orr
came on remember and so I was like I and
I looked out and Tommy he didn't look
happy and I was like either he hated the
movie or he's like angry that this guy
yeah yeah so I tried to get him up
remember and then he wouldn't come and
the crowd everyone started chanting
cheer I still get chills thinking about
that because we keep talking about how
that moment may have been the first time
Tommy has heard like an ironic applies
because like arm
we never intended to make fun of the
room or Tommy
on the contrary we want it to be a
celebration of him and a celebration of
people who were going after their dreams
and not taking no for an answer and so
when an audience of a thousand people
just start chanting Tommy Tommy it was
really it was really special yeah and
then I did also sit through the second
showing of the room afterwards I'm that
girl yes but I'd glad you bring it up
because when you just said the line just
now you put on the affectation of like I
don't even know if you know you did it
just now because you got a little Tommy
in you what was it like being directed
by your brother who you like know and
love but in like Tommy ISM yeah what it
like being directed by mastered the
rocks are see that doesn't faze me at
all
he I'm used to whatever he's gonna throw
my way these days but people it was
definitely an adjustment period
especially for Seth Rogen who took about
two two and a half weeks to fully get
used to him and character to the point
where he couldn't even be like in the
same room with James unless he was
actually in the scene with him but I
don't know it just added to the whole
like meta weirdness of it all and
ultimately I think just put us all on
the right headspace awesome yeah and
then obviously embodying him I want you
to talk a little bit about like your
kinship with Tommy and then yours also
with Greg because you're portraying
real-life people so that's like kind of
a hard thing sometimes you mean my
kinship with the actual Tommy were like
getting into the character and below him
because I feel like you as a director
and him as a director I've heard Seth
talk about it that you all have kind of
like a little Brotherhood a bit because
yeah maybe people don't always get your
vision as well well when we made the
movie
I didn't all I knew about Tommy was
really what I read in the book and but
in addition to that I actually was given
this amazing gift by Greg Sestero Tommy
used to record every phone conversation
he ever had he would drive around in his
car with
old-fashioned tape recorders with the
actual tape limine tapes and talked to
himself and have very emotional deep
conversation with himself and Danny I
don't know what he ever intended to do
with these things but 20 years ago Greg
took some of those tapes and digitize
them and Tommy knows I have them now so
it's not like unethical or whatever but
I got these incredibly private moments
it's like I like I call it the audio
book of Tommy's journal you know read by
the man and it was as an actor getting
in the character of wisdom
congratulations on the film I actually
saw it it's off by I was there that
night and it was awesome I know you guys
weren't there but you were mostly what
was it like that night seeing it with
that crowd for the first time it was
amazing
South bys has been like very good to us
over the years and honestly like several
of our movies that ultimately were
released well and received well and did
well would not it wouldn't have happened
if we didn't premiere them at South by
they really like framed us in a way that
allowed us to go on and succeed which is
nice for smaller movies you need that
and that night was crazy because the
first time Tommy saw the movie and we
really didn't know what he was gonna say
or think and there was the moment at the
end where we all got up on stage and we
were like do we invite Tommy up and I
didn't want to because I can't be like
what if he gets up and he's like [ __ ]
this movie like who's like that was just
like just destroy everything like right
out of the gate it must be like oh they
made a movie that the guy who it's about
says it's not real it hates it and like
it would have just been a nightmare and
then there was a moment where people
kind of like noticed he was there and it
was almost like the end of this movie
where people kind of started chanting
like for him to go up on stage and it
was like one of the weirdest like and I
was so nervous and then he came up and
he liked it ultimately and kind of gave
it his blessing and his fur on tomatoes
would be a very good
I know worse never but for you guys
after that like I feel like I was a
fangirl at that moment but then I was
trying to tell people I'm like James
Franco and them have made this like
comedic masterpiece and people are like
what they didn't get it so what was it
like for you guys explaining it to
people when you got involved like what
you were doing well I think the problem
with the room is that last year there
was a very successful oscar-winning
movie called the ring yes when you try
to explain what the room was when I said
comedic when I said masterpiece people
like I'll see you midnight I'm like no I
think it's tricky because the room is
still like very neat it's like it's not
out there and but I think with the cool
thing about this movie is it transcends
just being like an inside baseball kind
of movie about this very small movie and
it tells the story about people trying
to create something bigger and if you
have not seen the room you're gonna want
to go out and see the room immediately
and then vice versa if you've seen the
room that's like perfect yeah yeah yeah
so were you guys fans of the room before
it so when you you knew going into it
right I didn't really know I knew ish a
little bit like people had talked about
it and I didn't get it I just liked it
didn't get what they were saying and
then when I watched it alone in my
apartment which is a horrible way to
watch it for the first time you're in
just like a pit of despair and reaching
for people that are very trapped is a
big part of the experience
otherwise your insuk used to like just
not because it's bad turn it off just
out of like sheer trying to avoid
driving you have to say right focus on
it where it's gonna go away
literally just like oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god like you just that's
why those are watching but I I do this
podcast about bad movies and Greg came
on before he wrote the book and that
really opened my mind to the story
behind the movie which was so much more
than
you never think there's a lot of bad
movies but this movie the story behind
it is legitimately fascinating I mean
you get this money from how do they do
this and and and the production that
went on for months and it I think that
is the most interesting thing because
there's so many bad movies but there's
not too many bad movies with a good
story behind them yeah I mean for you
guys as artists we all put y'all put
stuff out there right would you rather
have a tommy moment or would you rather
have this like small niche thing that
nobody ever saw where you're like okay I
haven't beloved by this thing that
people kind of like ironically or would
you rather have this just this little
cult thing nobody sees it but you love
it which one would you rather do rather
like the lobster or the room I mean
probably the lobster yeah the hardest
thing about having a Tommy moment is
then what do you do after the Tommy
moment you know I think you can get more
work by having a small thing lobster you
make that sacred deer movie and then I
also want to talk to you guys about
James as a director because I feel like
there's been a lot made about the fact
that it took you a while to maybe not
crack up when he was acting as Tommy
directing what about you guys did y'all
did y'all get it right away when he's
like okay he's gonna direct me as Tommy
well it was right because even though I
had done this I'd done a movie with
James like eight or nine years ago this
movie called an American crime as a
better child abuse case in the 60s in
Indiana which is a very different thing
but I hadn't seen him in years so I I
like didn't really I feel like I didn't
really meet James again until after the
movie like I forgot that he was
different than the James the Tommy
version of James yes I was coming before
all of us to get into makeup and
prosthetics and everything so by the
time we arrived he was already
transformed or almost transformed and
then you know and they wouldn't be James
again until he was like weird to see him
now yeah
[Music]